all right let's run with D for for the
win or is it going to be for the win ah
Knight f3 I guess we're going to have a
king size fiend keto and in response to
that I am going to run with a quiet
approach actually let me do this i might
play III maybe i'll go for a double
fiend kettle I don't want to declare my
light square Bishop sand tensions okay
now let's come here actually maybe I
could get in this move with tempo and
I'm going to go for it doublethink keto
I don't have to worry about c2 because i
have night 83 as a response so that's
what i was referring to right then and
I'm looking forward to Bishop g2 let's
go here right now Bishop g2 Queen i'm
also i want to do this right now because
Queen to a5 might be a threat so I'm
looking forward to now night here with
the expansion in the center and maybe
first kick that night away in fact let
me take the night away he has to run to
the edge since c6 has been played and
i'm debating whether it's oh now this is
all the more appealing because of this
with a fork and i think this night runs
the risk of getting pushed around quite
a bit my opponent just dropped a piece i
think they were missing that i had
enough control over this square or maybe
i have missed something let me calculate
here because oh no actually I'm pond
push okay i'm getting forked right there
but um what's the scoop I don't have to
push this pond though I could just focus
on the space advantage I have actually
I'm going to run with the variation
where I am trying to take out that
bishop from the ball game and let's do
that so Queen here at the end of that I
was thinking here and then meet the
night move with Queen here take the
bishop and allow my rep to be taken but
after the rook is taking the nike
this night here I'm going to go with
this age three and then g4 and then f5
so I have a a giant wall of ponds right
here and these these pond pushes are
directed at restraining this light
square Bishop so I've a lot of space
here let's shut this Bishop down and
next up do what since I have a space
advantage I don't really want to trade
pieces that's one thing and that night
needed some repositioning so let's get
him working and capturing on that square
I don't know about that let me actually
do this let me put more pressure on this
point they're going to capture I
recapture and now it's my bishop on that
becomes a central pawn to play opposite
the Queen so this is still renewed pawn
takes pawn and I may be wanting to just
push up here real soon might we see
Queen a5 we are seeing that pond push
pawn push pawn push here I'm going to
run with this one and then maybe even
trade Queens I think in an endgame I'll
stand better my pieces again I have a
bunch of space and now that move right
there is one that I really did not
consider much let's do this to defend I
think it should be alright maybe Queen
to f2 as a follow-up but actually not so
fast Queen here I think is going to be
better I missing anything let me do this
watch over that so the night can maybe
be getting to this square but I think I
have everything under control we're
going to see about that though might
night right here be a good idea now I
could take in this direction so clean
trade on the on the cards here or not I
really don't want to trade Queens but
I'd do this though hit the Queen and
then come back actually no my night is
around to watch over this and so too is
my queen how about pushing here or maybe
playing here or centralizing my rook
I like this one getting my light squared
Bishop around in fact I want to get it
working over here maybe I'm this
diagonal so let's do that i'm looking at
also a push here assuming pushes like
that and queen is quite active
let's play here actually this is a
little bit sensitive without a doubt
okay that move um let's push the night's
gonna be posting up right there I think
I need to just get rid of that night can
i make that happen soon gonna try it it
needs to go actually night right here
could be quite good oh that's a good
move it's definitely a good move okay I
really want to hang on to my light
square Bishop still don't want to trade
maybe I'm needing to how about how about
pawn push well that's not really working
mmm what's the scoop here if I back up
there's like a knight move to hear
something back up hopefully this works
night right here is uh I think that
would have been a good move actually um
dropping a pond with this but i'm hoping
to get play on the B file I want to play
on the B file so can I get that beep on
I think everything is coordinated
otherwise that Bishop is still out of
play and i think i'm going to run with
this my queen is defended and my rook is
here there is this night move i'm on the
night though right there let me attack
it one minute 21 seconds i want to do a
pawn push i think it's coming together
now or is it I want to keep my rook
active actually let me do this and then
come over here if it's attacked again I
want to keep my rook active right there
so let's keep him active and I'm once
again looking for this pawn push where
I'm on g7 this Bishop there's back rank
mates another bad thing about that is
the back rank made so back up still
looking for this converging on g7 and f7
you do it right now this could get
really brutal really fast ok and now and
now what next get my night doing what um
let's do this you were that since I
can't converge on that anymore well
let's come back actually I'm going to go
in a different direction right here or
is that night going to go and let's take
this out I think in this end game I
stand better confirm eights there's
still back ranked mate issues can't be
taken because it's me I'm really low on
time though the rook still can't leave
just yet and grab this pond and then
come back push that pond actually why
haven't I been pushing that pawn push it
a couple times in fact maybe get my um
this box this on night out I guess look
right here is good let me come back have
much time okay I have a I have a game
plan it's to do this their King and
Bishop is stuck what's the winning plan
I just want to get the winning plan here
night right here
okay i have the winning idea i think you
give that up
and
okay this is going to get pretty tricky
right here I don't know why that move
was played this is one but it's very
difficult without a doubt very very
difficult I get that King okay i have
this actually now can i get a mate i'm
going to dry for me where is the mate
Nate's Nate's for the tricky mates mmm
where's the forks
ah it's gonna be a trade I couldn't get
it no material oh good game maybe I
should have recaptured that pond right
away good game right here in that end
game right here I was wondering about
what what was I wondering about I was
wondering about the King position let me
finally get there and why did I give up
that pot at the end okay of course I
didn't have any time but back here oh
this right here I should have just
calmly recaptured even right now right
now actually just recapture right now
and then just inch my king up or
something but I should have had
something back here earlier there's
definitely stuff that I missed my
opponent was in a knot and I just didn't
have the time to figure out how to
squeeze things tighter but I'm good game
let some backup I don't know I there's
this was a weird thing for me to see a
group of three pawns right here so I was
feeling pretty good I think I think
white is just better here with this
tsunami of ponds and the bishop kind of
dead which turned out to be a big
problem so the improvement is somewhere
where I wonder
c6 supposed to be played or something i
wonder if that was a mouse slip or
something because i'm able to keep that
night away to the edge and the deck I
guess the night move all together I
don't know if this is doing much night
before just night 83 and then I don't
know
not sure I maybe this Bishop deployment
to f5 really isn't working well with
this d6 move like if this is ever played
then that's one less squared the bishop
has maybe just going with the more
standard kingside phim keto and then I'm
not able to grab so much space excuse me
no this is this is the most testing line
that I've seen against this white set up
just going with g6 Bishop g7 but um
other than that I don't know that was
that was really tight middle game I
don't know if grabbing my beep on was a
good choice I don't know what I could
have done better let's see um hmm
that Queen was a pest that Queen was the
best I really didn't want things to open
up actually over on the wing maybe I
shouldn't move my rook how about
actually pushing here I would have been
a lot cleaner maybe put pressure on this
and then push forward yeah that's maybe
a better way to go or something by me
and it should still be good I think
actually I'm in trouble right here this
is something that was scaring me I
wonder about night right here with the
fork picking on my dark square Bishop
and then planting the bishop here that
could be I think brutal so I think that
that was maybe better and I the tables I
think might be turning actually although
I guess this is still an issue in nearly
every variation just that it's not doing
anything and there's still back rank
mate issues for black so yeah I don't
know this has to be good for me just a
giant pig you know on the 7th and this
is a problem in fact as soon as I get
this structure and even if I'm down upon
or something everything keeps pointing
at this bish of not being able to do
anything and I know that feeling on a
very recent note by the way because I
played a GM in blitz recently and that's
exactly how he punished me something
where my bishop was just locked out of
the game because of this structure was
something i was aware of but up to the
time in the game i just wasn't able to
prevent it when it happened i was just
dead so but i didn't i didn't execute
good enough in this end game my opponent
put up good resistance there had to have
been something good here maybe giving up
the dark sir bishop was just completely
unnecessary how about just do the move I
was going to do a second like my second
move Knight d4 why not just do 94 right
now keep my phone and constrained to the
defense of the night in some fashion
right because 94 this night can't move
otherwise I take and then there's that
back rank mate stuff I should have maybe
gotten this pond pushing sooner or even
this how about this one how about bishop
here followed by push push that seems
clean as I was talking about like just
right now seeing it Bishop b5 maybe
Bishop d7 get this guy going he's two
steps away I was fiddling around too
much with my minor pieces I guess by
good game good resistance in a tough
spot right there